Here we've zoomed in on the relevant portion of the globe.
We can see Syene and Alexandria.
Now, here the sun's rays strike vertically,
which by vertical we mean perpendicular  to the earth.
Here at Alexandria, it doesn't strike vertically.
If I drew a line perpendicular to the earth,
I can see there's some angle here,
which we don't know just yet.
Now, we're trying to find the circumference of the earth.
We found out that as we move further north from Alexandria
this angle actually gets bigger
and the shadow gets bigger as well.
It seems like there's some relationship--hopefully a mathematical one--
between this angle and the circumference of the earth.
Let's see if we can figure it out.
I'm actually going to start by making a wish list.
This wish list is going to contain everything
that I wish I knew in order to solve this problem.
Hopefully, we'll be able to come back to it later
and address everything on it.
I wish I knew this angle, and I'm going to call it the Greek letter α.
We're dealing with the Greeks. Why not use the Greek letter?
It's pretty common to call angles α in physics.
Okay, so on my wish list, I wish I had that angle--the angle α.
Now, what are we going to do with this angle α?
Let's not even worry about how to calculate it yet.
What are we going to do with it?
Well, whenever I get stuck on a geometry problem,
I start drawing lines, and they usually help me.
Since a circle is involved here, or a sphere--
but we're only looking at a circular cross section of it--
drawing lines from the center is usually a good idea.
So, I'm going to draw a line from the center to Syene
and from the center to Alexandria.
Okay, now there's still now a ton jumping out to me.
Maybe I'll extend this line--that sometimes helps me see what's going on.
Ah! Okay. Something just jumped out to me.
This angle α shows up in more than one place.
I'll tell you there are other angles on this drawing
that are equal to α--maybe one, maybe more.
I'm going to mark some contenders and why don't you tell me which ones are correct.
What about this angle? Is that equal to α?
Check that box if you think it is.
Or what about this angle? Is that equal to α?
This one? Or what about this one?
For this quiz, just go ahead and check all of the angles that you think are equal to this one.